hey what's going on is Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday October 15 2018 what's going on
how uh yeah you hear the echo echo echo
I am in New York City everybody I am
here for the next 2-3 days I'm doing a
bunch of press to promote my show at
Madison Square Garden on November 7th of
this same year of our Lord and the
Chinese chicken whatever the [ __ ]
Chinese whatever's is it the year of the
monkey I was here I was born I was born
in the year of the monkey you know I
find that very offensive I am NOT a
monkey yeah yeah I'm a dancing monkey I
was born in the Chinese New Year of the
dancing monkey
Shanghai's [ __ ] joke sorry
do a little raishin right there didn't
my work anyways what's good could I be
having a better sports weekend I mean I
got to tell you if I'm built there I got
to be pretty [ __ ] happy with what I
sell this day doing the bookie boob-tube
you would think you would think that I
would be excited last night that my New
England Patriots that I would be excited
that they knocked off the undefeated
Kansas City Chiefs okay now obviously I
am happy that we won the [ __ ] game
but if somebody's gonna sit there and
tell me that that's what a football game
is going to look like in the future
I don't even know what that was like
watching two people playing Madden
football you know it reminded me of the
Super Bowl last year where there was
just no defense and you know who likes
[ __ ] like that people who aren't fans of
the [ __ ] game I just you know Tyree
kill everybody how many how many [ __ ]
times was he gonna do
was he gonna catch a [ __ ] ball it was
like that when Tom Brady goes down leads
us down like he always [ __ ] does for
the go-ahead score all right
Tyree kill number 10
and you [ __ ] playbook and your program
a little [ __ ] accountant who doesn't
watch sports would be like hey you know
I don't want to come off like a
know-it-all
I barely watch this game but I'm gonna
say you might want to cover that number
10 guy my home comes up like Jack
[Music]
[ __ ] the guy goes up untouched
running across the middle of a [ __ ]
NFL defense unfuckin touched
tralala catches the [ __ ] ball I don't
know I was in a sports part was it 60 70
80 [ __ ] yards untouched who would
have thought that Patrick show Todd by
hope was gonna go to [ __ ] the guy
he'd been going to who had been killing
you the whole [ __ ] game I understand
if the guy beats you I understand and I
say yeah I understand that but to
basically not even cover the guy doesn't
that I mean I would expect to see some
play like that in Central Park watching
a couple of Wall Street Psychopaths
playing [ __ ] touch football that was
pathetic
it was [ __ ] pathetic alright haven't
said that I love Patrick mahomes I'm
sold on the guy now all right
I don't crown somebody King in September
of their first [ __ ] year as a starter
but yes yes that [ __ ] amazing just an
amazing beast of a [ __ ] player having
said that I don't know what in the I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
dude that [ __ ] guy in the Kansas City
Chiefs where they're trying to suggest
that this he had Tom Brady for a sack
and he's like oh don't hurt the
quarterback and then he [ __ ] he runs
in for a touchdown it's just like I you
know I understand I guess because of the
the concussions
in the long-term effects I guess I have
to adjust how I watch the game and when
it comes to quarterback who's kidding
he'll all right those are the hot chicks
okay they're not paying a cover they're
not buying a drink you know they're
gonna be sitting there looking at their
[ __ ] Instagram bored out of their
[ __ ] minds because they get
everything that's what a quarterback is
gonna be all right depending on what
they're doing for the league because
those are the ones that you know bring
in the money but that you know I don't
know it's fun to watch all of that
offense but like watching that watching
a guy sack a quarterback and then unset
him because he doesn't want to get in
trouble and then seeing that same guy
who runs worse than me score a touchdown
I guess was fun because that was a
Patriots fan but it's a fan of football
I mean I don't know I guess I would him
I remember a long time ago I watched an
NFL Films and this is before you know
they started overly protecting
quarterbacks and you know leading with
your shoulder which i think is a good
thing who's good knew I not to project
overly protecting the quarterbacks I
don't like that at all but I've never
seen this old school football guy player
he played in the 1950s or 40s and they
asked him what you thought about today's
NFL and this was like in the 90s and he
just was talking through his teeth he's
like I would like your foot will give to
Dave you look he almost [ __ ] me his
head almost exploded steam coming out of
his ears and I was just laughing going
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with this
guy and now that I am old enough to have
seen the game change as much as it has I
feel like I'm turning into that guy hey
Bill what you think about your team
beating the Chiefs last night well you
look you know do you know it covergirl
like I'm [ __ ] dude I was in this
sports bar and the whole game it was
just people screaming oh my god oh my
god oh my god it was like they were
trying an eight-year-old try to land a
jumbo jet was the energy in the [ __ ]
ruining me you know I which I guess is
great Oh bye
the way epic [ __ ] sports bar guy I
really learned how much people hate the
[ __ ] Patriots with the [ __ ] they
hatred this guy had to he literally got
he got thrown out of the bar like he was
[ __ ] Earl Weaver it was like I
sweated I was like watching a baseball
manager get ejected he got thrown out of
a sports bar not for fighting because
how much he was yelling at the [ __ ]
TV like completely lost his composure I
saw so much of me in this guy but it's
like I do it in private I do it when I'm
driving a car or when I'm at home with
my wife which is why you know she
[ __ ] you know doesn't like me now she
likes me but I mean I'm tough to live
with this [ __ ] guy was like when the
you know Patriots went out big right 24
to whatever you know when the chief
started coming back this guy like he
just [ __ ] lost it he liked the whole
night was [ __ ] hilarious I went in
there with a friend of mine and we were
we will meet another buddy of mine and I
was texting him going hey man we're
almost here alright wait you know we're
pulling up and he's like cool cool right
so I go in there I don't see him
something like I'll [ __ ] that's weird i
can't believe i [ __ ] beat this guy
here so we grab a table then we go you
know we got one other guy coming so we
grabbed a four-top and was sitting there
and the Patriots scored a touchdown and
I just hear this [ __ ] guy just be
like yeah that's what I'm talking about
America like just being an idiot and I'm
like who the [ __ ] is that jackass I look
down it's my buddy that I'm supposed to
be [ __ ] hanging out with so me and my
friend we left together [ __ ] me go over
there Sonny so we sit down so that's the
first clue that there was going to be
this lunacy so at that point we've gone
up like 20
forty like [ __ ] three or six or
something like that it was like wow man
then mop on the floor with these guys
this is crazy right and all of a sudden
the Chiefs start coming back it's like
24 13 24 20 and this [ __ ] guy down
the end of the bar man and he looked
like he was older than me you know but
at this point at my age I probably was
[ __ ] five seven years older than this
guy right but um but I'm in Hollywood so
I take care of myself I drink plenty of
water I use lotions this [ __ ] guy was
agent like that [ __ ] Quint in and
jaws right so he's down
you know when the chief scored this the
first time she's cause he's like yeah
alright you know and then when they
scored the second time he just started
yelling like that's right that's right
it's 2018 this is the new this is the
new NFL it's [ __ ] over for you who's
yelling about the Patriots he was so
sick of them winning and and dude I'm
telling you and then the Patriots of
course come back and match it and you
know we got a couple of pass
interference calls and this [ __ ] guy
was losing his [ __ ] and just getting
madder and madder and it's it started
off what he would yell about the play
and then yell about it for three minutes
and then it just was five minute
segments and then he was just yelling at
the [ __ ] TV and he had just
completely lost all composure and the
Patriots went up by seven again and they
look like they were pulling away he
missed the whole end of the [ __ ] game
I just wish he was like it was getting
you know the old me would have engaged
with this guy you know because I was
having a couple of pops but I was kind
of like you know older and wiser
you know when the Chiefs went up by
three points and he was when he was
screaming this is the new rule blah blah
blah I did one point one point yell down
I went
regular-season because he was starting
to annoy me and then he just completely
yet like I said he was just yelling like
I mean the only thing was missing was
this guy like
just if they had a home plate on the
barroom floor and he could have just
pushed the dirt all over it I mean he
completely [ __ ] lost it and was just
gonna [ __ ] represent [ __ ]
Pittsburgh a [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and everybody in here knows it he said
that everybody in here knows it and I
was just I I was like yeah I was just
like is that what I look like
that's [ __ ] I'm this guy but he took
it to her next in like the next level
you know what I mean what you thought
like you know it was like I was [ __ ]
Michael Jordan of losing my [ __ ] you
know and then along comes Kobe Bryant
you're like oh whoa I thought it well
that's not a good comparison because he
wasn't better I don't know Dan Marino
right that's not a good comparison
because Dan Marino would've thrown for
6,000 you know whatever yo your [ __ ]
Hall of Famer you put up all these
[ __ ] no one's ever gonna catch this
guy
and then all of a sudden you see
yourself get talks you're like wow man
records really are meant to be broken
even the ones no one wants to break so I
guess they had been warning the guy
because I got to the point where it was
kind of like he basically turned
everybody into the bar into like his kid
and he was the dad driving the car and
everybody was just sort of be looking
around like who dad's really getting
worked up today huh and he was with this
woman and she was just smiling looking
down at the bar I mean she couldn't have
been with him she would she would have
been mortified I don't know or she's
just the biggest say never and she just
what I like I like a passionate fella so
anyways the bouncer comes in and
literally just taps him on the shoulders
like you have to go and he put his
jacket on he didn't resist on any level
but he never stopped yelling
and screamed the whole way out of the
bar it was like it was literally like
performance art and and everybody in the
park just had like such like a funny
attitude towards it like there was no
none of that [ __ ] [ __ ] that goes on
today where that triggered me and is
this a safe space it was none of that
people were just laughing just watching
like one of the most epic [ __ ]
frustrated sports fans I've ever seen I
mean I actually started I did I start
tried to start the slow clap when he was
being escorted out you know I just felt
like the guy he deserved a round of
applause I haven't I don't I've never
seen anybody like you know back in the
day they came up with something in the
70s because people were we're throwing
[ __ ] at their TVs and they were breaking
him while they were watching television
so somebody invented like this thing it
looked like a brick but it was soft and
you could throw it but he'd this you
know eventually that went away because
the satisfaction is the sound of glass
shattering you know of breaking the
thing that's making you a [ __ ] either
you know is not working for you speaking
as a person with the temper right you
wanna you want you want the inanimate
object to pay which is why I remember a
long time ago when this actor I'm not
gonna say his [ __ ] name whatever but
he was trying to call his wife and the
[ __ ] phone wasn't working and he
called down to the hotel the front desk
and they couldn't help him make it work
so he ripped it out of the wall and he
went downstairs and he threw it he threw
the phone at the [ __ ] guy
you know the guy got a little cut on his
head and [ __ ] but I gotta be honest with
you like as much as he shouldn't have
done that I can't imagine the release
that that must have been how satisfied
he literally took the thing that wasn't
working and he threw it at the person
that couldn't help him make it work I
mean that is just like you know two for
two right but that's like a that's like
pitching a perfect game in anger
so anyways hats off to that [ __ ] guy
hats off to Patrick mahomes he's [ __ ]
amazing Chiefs have a great [ __ ] team
but like you know I don't know how
anybody thinks either one of those teams
is gonna win the [ __ ] Super Bowl you
can't they both let up 40 in was it
forty and forty three points and
everybody's I remember seeing that back
in the [ __ ] day like that was how the
dolt the Dolphins never won when they
had Dan Marino because they had no
[ __ ] defense it was just like all
right dad you know we're gonna give up
35 38 points do you got 40 Enya again
today he had to go out and score [ __ ]
40 points so he could win by two or
three and those teams never won Super
Bowls into this [ __ ] day he gets [ __ ]
for it like they blamed the one guy who
wasn't a problem they blamed the [ __ ]
guy that got him to as far as they could
[ __ ] go before they would run into a
[ __ ] great defense which would you
know knock down whatever Dan was gonna
do by seven to 10 points but his [ __ ]
defense would still give up the [ __ ]
35 38 points and then they'd lose and
then everybody who can't win the big one
you know [ __ ] Joe Montana couldn't
win the big one with those [ __ ]
defenses I mean how many times you got
to watch sports defense wins
championships okay I don't know what the
[ __ ] everybody's so excited about last
night's goddamn game watching two teams
giving up 44 I can't wait to you know
come playoff time could playoff play
right anyway so meanwhile on a TV screen
right next to it was the Red Sox and the
Astros now I was out doing spots so I
miss like the first half of the game I
can't by the time I came in it was five
to four
I don't know how priced looked or
whatever I got to go read some [ __ ] on
it but I think he left at five four so I
believe if if Kimbrel hadn't let that
run in to make it seven to five I used
to know how this works I think he would
have got the victory so if that is the
case then he kind of got screwed out of
an out of a win last night but I gotta
tell you the Astros [ __ ] led us up
off the map because obviously going up
to ou was huge but the thing was they
beat sale and that's what the Yankees
had to do they had to beat sale because
then you get the price and price has not
won in October so you basically got
yourself two [ __ ] wins and put the
Yankees they got the first two out of
three that they needed and even with the
Astros if you win the first two [ __ ]
games the other team has to win for the
next five and you just have to go two
and three see it's all about the math so
um you know I did not have high hopes
for how we were gonna look against the
Astros and how Game one went down was
well how I thought the series was going
to go down but after watching last night
I was like alright you know this is the
[ __ ] Sylvester Stallone ain't so bad
it's over but they are an incredible
[ __ ] team so we shall see hey who's
that bearded guy with the Bob Stanley
body that we have in middle relief that
guy's been doing alright when I saw him
I had flashbacks to 1986 with Bob
Stanley running out of the bullpen I
mean that [ __ ] guy I swear to God
like he had like a cop body like a
stereotypical like like bad cop I don't
mean crooked cop
I mean like you know just you know you
just keep every year you just order a
bigger uniform you know one of those
[ __ ] guys and then just coming
running out
yeah there's skinny [ __ ] legs and his
flabby [ __ ] I mean how would you like
a professional athlete and then you
can't take your shirt off at the pool
you know it's just [ __ ] unbelievable
to me that's basically the body that guy
had so old muffin-top Johnson whoever
the [ __ ] we have on coming out in middle
relief that guy's he's just been aces
he's been [ __ ] aces and Kimbrel just
you know you die a thousand [ __ ]
deaths with that guy it's just like he's
gonna let in at least one run is what
I've just come to expect and this [ __ ]
that I say when he holla this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] hook on son of
a bow you file yeah of course of course
you walk him right I like the second he
gets in the game I stand up and I just
start pacing and I know that like I'm
also a lunatic but I hats off to that
[ __ ] guy like that guy last night
he's one of those grown men that when
his team finally wins it like he's he's
gonna [ __ ] cry like he's like this is
the new NFL tit like how much it meant
to him for his team to win and how sick
he was of the Patriots just [ __ ]
getting all the calls and all the [ __ ]
that you say about all the all the
[ __ ] great teams I [ __ ] been there
and I was just to watch it it was I
really learned a lot about myself it's
very rare that you see two exciting
games like that and then somebody's
behavior is at the same level I mean all
three of them were we racist but uh
Jesus Christ has that mahomes kid good
my god I wish that Monday night guy
didn't [ __ ] hype them up so much and
make me a [ __ ] contrarian like tap
into that [ __ ] it's like can you just
let me watch him be great and then I can
say he's great rather than you spoon
feeding what I'm supposed to beat there
I hope you realize what you just saw all
right buddy
dial it down that reminds me of like
when that woman with the Yankees the
Roger Clemens called Roger Roger Clemens
oh my goodness gracious what both of
them should be doing wrestling by the
way I want to thank everyone that came
out in Saginaw Michigan first of all I
landed at the airport and I swung by the
old address where my great-grandparents
lived they had a house and my
great-grandfather evidently dug the
basement by hand
stubborn German guy right and I don't
buy it by the way I don't know how the
[ __ ] you do that without your house
falling down into the hole
I would imagine you'd have to start in
the middle of the room work your way out
and then pick one side you know and as
you started to do it you have to put
something underneath the [ __ ]
foundation because I wouldn't feel safe
going within two feet of whatever dirt
the [ __ ] foundation was sitting on I
don't know how the [ __ ] you do that but
my buddy was laughs because we slowly
showed up to where the house was
supposed to be the address and there was
no house there anymore that was the
effect a lot of in that area you know
the houses are obviously my
great-grandparents lived there one
hundred [ __ ] years ago so the house
is no longer there it's not like it was
knocked down they put up something new
was just like an empty lot and my buddy
was joking and being like well you know
your grandfather dug a basement here
maybe that's why the house isn't he here
anymore but I got to tell you man that
theater that I played in the sound in
that theater was incredible it's just it
was such a live theater it was
incredible as I have and there's another
one he could take the [ __ ] special in
here and the crowd was awesome and
you know I was teasing him about [ __ ]
you know being farmers and all of that
dumb [ __ ] that I do and you know we were
gonna try to drive and right down to Ann
Arbor for the human University of
Michigan Wisconsin Badger game the next
day we meet somebody's in a bar and all
of that [ __ ] by the way yes sober
October is just out the window for me
it's not happening all right I'm having
a bad year next year next year I'll win
the title so anyways I was saying in my
head all right I usually do like upwards
of 90 minutes I'll probably do like an
hour and 15 jump in the car I'm gonna
get the [ __ ] out here blah blah blah all
that [ __ ] and I had such a good time
painted of doing like an hour 30 an hour
35 ended up going out doing like the
meet-and-greet thing and but it still
all worked out because we found this bar
that was open till 2:00 in the morning
and me and my buddies you know furs e
bartnik and our two other buddies that
we go to the games with every year we
would have been such a good [ __ ] time
just laughing it's like the most laughs
I've had on a weekend just laughing of
[ __ ] asses off just breaking each
other's balls and we were just having
such a good time and we were so excited
about the game the next day you know
like all this like the people that work
there they just start liking you then
they were coming over and you know next
thing you know the bar is closed and
like all right let's just go downstairs
because it was a downstairs area so we
don't get in trouble and then we stayed
down there till like [ __ ] 4:00 in the
morning
so thank God it was a 7:30 game so the
next day we [ __ ] wake up and we go
out to go with some eat before we head
over to the tailgate when I meet you
meeting a bunch of other friends you
know some of my relatives and all that
[ __ ] to tailgate before we go into the
[ __ ] big house right this is my
weekend ridiculous right so we go out to
this place to get something to eat man
I'll tell you like when I tell you
everything was just okay
it was all almost like that almost
tasted good you know how long it took
for the food to get out they didn't
clear off any of the [ __ ] plates
it was so [ __ ] funny like this it was
just one of the worst run places I've
been to in a long time and like I
remember at one point we I just saw this
random you know person who worked there
go by and I just say excuse me uh can we
get our can we get our check she's like
you're gonna have to ask your server and
I don't know who that is and I'm looking
at it like well go [ __ ] find out and
then you know of course she doesn't I
finally see our server and I do that and
then she said comes up she goes excuse
me the people over there trying to say
that you're somebody are you somebody
are you are you Bill Maher is what she
said which was so [ __ ] perfect
because the food all the food was almost
good and then she almost recognized me
and almost got my name right so we were
[ __ ] crying laughing about how they
just kept almost and then she goes what
is your name and I go Michael and she
goes Michael who and I go straight in
and then afterwards I go no no no I am I
go um actually bill burr Bill Maher does
and she goes all right she goes so who
was the guy you said you were I said
Michael straining he goes I used to play
for the New York Giants now he does one
of those morning talk shows and she goes
Oh what so like you think that you know
because I work in a sports bar that you
just got to say like a sports person's
name that's kind of stereotypical isn't
it and I looked at her like Isiah am I
getting like me too dry toe
like what the [ __ ] kind of energy is
that you know really that that part was
like [ __ ] annoying to me like like
how [ __ ] full of yourself are you you
know do you think that's all I am as a
person is that any [ __ ] know you the
only reason why I said stray hands
because I didn't think there'd be a
follow-up question to Michael
I was the first name I thought him
anyway so I did stand-up last night at
Gotham comedy club and I was having a
great time until I started making fun of
women and then everybody just [ __ ]
pulls back it's one of my issues with
[ __ ] doing stand-up in New York City
now is everybody is so air-quote woke
it's like you it's like doing stand-up
at a [ __ ] woman's college I feel like
I'm performing in front of old people on
a cruise ship and you look at them and
they're like half my age and they're
borderline Fanning themselves and you're
just looking at like guys I'm 50 you
should be shocking me I'll tell you this
[ __ ] generation it's not Millennials
it's the generation that you know what
is it Z whatever the [ __ ] they call
these [ __ ] people the the level of
midlife crisis that these people are
gonna have it's just gonna be off the
[ __ ] it's gonna be off the [ __ ]
rails so anyways after crying laughing
the night before we were in this place
the we would call it the almost
something-or-other just crying laughing
it just how poorly run the [ __ ] thing
was right then we're out in the parking
lot we're trying to decide alright are
we gonna over over there other thing you
know cuz ubers just taken forever to
call or whatever and so we finally
decide we're gonna over and we just
started singing this brute Bruce
Springsteen song just trashing each
other you know uh hold on oh we just
kept doing that Oh making fun of bartnik
because he was driving Joe can't see
[ __ ] he's like farsighted so he could
see the [ __ ] big house from Saginaw
but he couldn't see the car [ __ ] two
feet in front of him and would drive in
it's raining out and furs he's in the
backseat like a quiver in his voice the
entire [ __ ] time and I've resigned
myself to the fact that we're gonna die
and Paul was mad at me that I didn't get
his upset as he was it's just like dude
we're doing 80 miles an hour with the
guy who can't see in the rain so what am
i Jack Ryan am I gonna [ __ ] reach
over and grab the wheel it's like we're
we're either gonna live or die you know
we're not walking away with severe
injuries this is going to be a fireball
death
so we just were singing I came home
cells Joe bartnik he can't see [ __ ]
changing blades in the rain I can't even
do it it might [ __ ] shredded my boys
doing it just trashing each other and it
just went all around poverty and the
whole [ __ ] thing and then they sang
one about me and we're just drinking in
his parking lot laughing like the whole
weekend was it just was one non-stop
[ __ ] laugh then we get to the
tailgate my buddies are on this golf
course and I have the uber drop us off
on the other side of the golf course we
had to walk like ten fairways and you
know the ball breaking started by the
second hole and I'm like I think it's
over the next hill yeah tell me the next
tillich with a [ __ ] we you know I
believe there was a Magellan reference I
can't even remember and we just [ __ ]
laughing right and we finally end up
finding finding the tailgate we're
throwing the football around but playing
that beanbag toss game or whatever that
one of the guys there
he made his own he built it from hand
and then he had in the hole he had it
lit he had like lights around the hole
on the inside it was just like to a
whole other level and it got really
[ __ ] competitive and virzi in this
dude al that we go with they would like
to - best I'm like you guys are the
dream team you got to take down the
dentist because this kid who was a
dentist was the guy who [ __ ] built
the thing himself cornhole I believe is
what the [ __ ] game's called and it
got to the point everyone was just so
[ __ ] into it right and I sucked at it
like I just kept going for the hole I
never got one to just I didn't you got
it like that Robert Parish foul shot
arty of [ __ ] so anyways was standing in
a plane and all of a sudden this [ __ ]
guy you know people kept walking between
us throwing and you know we will take in
our time letting people pass and one guy
I swear to God look like the dude from
[ __ ] radio
he just comes walking up and he's
[ __ ] hammered real slowly and then I
tried to grab one of the bags out of my
buddy's hands and you know he's sort of
a Midwest guy so they do you know those
guys they got like a long fuse Midwest
people but you know when they snap
forget about it because they like had to
pick up tractors when they were kids so
they [ __ ] squeeze you to death so he
kind of chills out and I got the East
Coast short fuse so I didn't like it
because he wasn't say anything and he
was just staring that kid down so I just
looked at him as a 50 year old man at a
tailgate I looked at him and I said the
[ __ ] is your problem like like I'm gonna
roll around on the grass with this guy
with my fucked-up shoulder my fifty year
old body right not even not even
thinking oh I've been p90x and had you
Bill you half a century old keep your
[ __ ] mouth shut and drink your
Rolling Rock but I didn't so what the
[ __ ] is your problem so he's walking
away and he stared at me and I'm [ __ ]
staring at him and I'm like going I'm
about ready to get into a fight what why
I got a kid like what am i doing but
like I'm not gonna [ __ ] look away
from this [ __ ] guy because as much of
some thinking that I [ __ ] hate this
kid right so he's staring at me he's
staring at me and then all of a sudden
and he won't stop staring as he's kind
of walking away and he's just as he's
getting into a distance of like alright
I think he's just gonna Bluff his way
out of this he [ __ ] walks into an
empty chair of somebody else's tailgate
and when I tell you it took like nine
seconds for this guy just slowly it was
like oh somebody chopped down a redwood
how long it took for him to fall and all
the tailgates because they were kind of
watching it the whole thing transpire
got like three tailgates as this guy
falls everywhere like OH
[Music]
the crowd and everybody's dying laughing
and then he stands up but he's still
staring at me like you ever see a drunk
guy fall down but he doesn't spill any
part of his beverage that's what he was
doing but with like a stare down he had
a cigarette that's what he had and he
[ __ ] hits the ground and he's still
staring at me that Radiohead with one
[ __ ] eye more open than the other one
and then he puts his cigarette in his
mouth and as he's getting up he's still
staring at me and he grabs the chair and
for half a second I'm like this [ __ ]
lunatic is gonna throw this chair at me
and he just stood the [ __ ] thing up
and then looked at everybody and did a
giant wave like it was the end of the
performance and I want to say he got an
applause break and he walked away so now
we're all once again crying laughing
[ __ ] crying laughter just having the
best time ever then we end up we end up
going into the game you know I'm a
couple of heaters in here so this is
when it becomes like the slideshow right
we're at the tailgate don't cheat now
we're getting checked by security
so we're [ __ ] going into the big
house and I'm telling my buddies I'm
like dude it's not going to look like
anything as you're walking up to it like
2/3 of it they dug it into the ground
it's when you go in there you see the
[ __ ] magnitude of this [ __ ] place
it's gonna be unreal so we walked in
there and one of my buddies I don't know
how he did it but you know you know
there's no booze in there he snuck an
entire fifth of Crown Royal I mean like
like the one Keith Richards would take a
swig out of sit down and he just pulls
it up and the people behind us laughed
it was so [ __ ] ridiculous that he got
it in they were just laughing at Jesus
they started laughing and we just shared
it with everyone around us so then we
were sort of like surround it was like
when you play chess and you build a
castle we did
would drunk people around us and it was
[ __ ] cold out and then we just kept
everybody warm and just Percy then and
then of then then the [ __ ] pregame
thing started I'm trying to find the
video they have James Earl Jones do it
and they're like we are though Michigan
Wolverines
we've won more games earlier the college
football team blah blah blah blah blah
and then at one point he goes we bow to
no one and we were just laughing like I
thought I'm ready to run through a
[ __ ] wall
and then the Wolverines come running out
we were sitting right on the 50-yard
line like 12 rows up we weren't too low
that you know you lose like depth of
perception you know we would sit in
perfectly and they all just come [ __ ]
running outta one whole side of a
hundred thousand people is screaming god
and then the other side would go mmm
it was [ __ ] just got chills and and
then the game started and [ __ ]
Michigan had their way with them thank
God because I did not want to see them
lose you know and I would get what a
ruined look experience I always would
for the [ __ ] whole team you know
unless LSU's play then the game was
great I mean it sucked if you were
badger fans because they kind of just
had their way with them but it was such
a [ __ ] like an amazing experience and
the amount of laughs that we had I
really think like we were all sitting
there talking ago I think that was the
best one I'm calling it right now we're
gonna have a hangover one next year
we're like last year when we went we
went to LSU Florida Gators and it was
just so [ __ ] hot out that it was it
was almost impossible to enjoy yourself
it was it was it was [ __ ] ridiculous
so I think next year we're gonna try to
go to Clemson I think we're going to try
to go to Clemson or something like that
and we're going to try to knock out all
those ones that are in like hurricane
you know part of the war
just so you know with global warming and
all of that [ __ ] we want to try to knock
those out before those stadiums are
underwater so it's so sad but what you
can't do any but laugh about it right
now I got a text this person back I'll
be there I'll be there 12:15 there we go
there we go
all right plowing analysts let me do a
couple of reads here let me do Jo
Bartnik okay here we go
Oh my bookie everybody oh Jesus Christ
by the way how bad were my picks one of
my locks of the weeks was the Giants
take the Giants with the points at home
holy [ __ ] sorry although I might be good
at picking games but you just listen to
me and you do the opposite I want to say
a couple of them came in I think I went
2 and 3 I think was more like 1 & 2 my
pick 3 game so either 2 & 1 or I went 1
wanted to I can't remember which alright
sure watching football is fun but it's
more entertaining when you got some
action on the game guys hear me talking
about this for weeks and some of you are
still on the sidelights whether you're
an expert or a rookie
you should be betting at my bookie if
you're the kind of guy that likes to bet
a little and win a lot like playing the
numbers on roulette you can create a big
payday parlay you pick three teams to
win you hit all three you could turn on
hundred dollars into six hundred dollars
there's so much to bet on playoff
baseball hockey primetime fights and
more but my pokey is the one bet I know
you'll be happy with all year all right
people recommend these guys and really
trust them my bookie has been in
business for years they got great online
reviews and their mobile site is easy to
use if you're on the sidelines now is
the time to get in the game my bookie
will still match your first deposit
dollar-for-dollar but you got to join
now because they'll be pulling that
offer log on to my bookie right now and
double your money use promo code
and you'll get your first deposit
matched 100% that's promo code burr you
play you win you get paid right you play
you win you get paid okay zero the hell
is this huh I don't know this one for
any smokers out there trying to quit if
you know someone who is there's a
revolutionary revolutionary new way to
quit called zero zeros quit kit is a new
quitting solution proven to increase
your chances of kicking the habit by up
to four times compared to going cold
turkey
talk about your experience or the
experience of someone you know who is
trying to quit smoking well I never
really I mean I smoked cigars but I
never did the cigarette the cigarette
thing is the hard thing and evidently
it's harder to quit than kick and heroin
so and that's all I know the zero quit
kit is a three tiered approach that
includes prescription medication
nicotine gum and continued support
through a mobile app here's how it works
go to quit with zero calm to start your
online doctor visit after your five
minute visit a physician will then
determine if you're eligible to use the
quit kit if you're eligible the doctor
will prescribe your medication and the
quit kit will be shipped directly to
your door zero cost less than what the
average smoker spends on cigarettes and
less than other quitting's options go to
quit with zero com / / and for a limited
time my listeners can get their first
month of the quit kit to stop smoking
for just thirty seven dollars that's
quit with zero com / / quit with zero
com / / that's like another [ __ ] thing
where you just realized that it really
is all about money you know because you
know we're allegedly fighting a war on
terror and you have a [ __ ] American
corporations that like literally put
glass in dip to give you microscopic
cuts so you get more of a buzz and get
more [ __ ] into it and just I mean they
literally killed people they're [ __ ]
mass mass murderers
mass [ __ ] murders you tell me what
Isis would do different with tobacco
they'd probably try to kill you a little
quicker those dumb [ __ ] they'd probably
put some [ __ ] explosives in it and
they'd only kill a few people then get
caught yeah but you know what I'm
telling you all you need to do to go
from being a terrorist to an upstanding
US citizen is just donate to a
politician's campaign and then you're in
the clear it's all you got to do
all right Dollar Shave Club Dollar Shave
Club has everything you need to look
feel and smell your best and you never
have to go to a store that's because
they deliver everything you need right
to your door and they keep you fully
stocked on what you use so you don't run
out here's how it works Dollar Shave
club's there's everything you need to
get ready no matter what you're getting
ready for they have you covered head to
toe for your you-know-what Oh your hair
your skin your face you name it they
have it and they have this new program
where they automatically keep you
stocked up on the products you use you
determine what you want and when you
want it and it shows up right at your
door from once a month to once every six
months plus with their handsome discount
the more you buy the more you save and
right now Dollar Shave Club has a bunch
of status sets you can try for just five
dollars like their oral care kit after
that the restock box ships regular size
products at regular price get your
starter set for just five dollars right
now at Dollar Shave Club dude
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / burn and lastly
but certainly not least Lee stamps.com
stamps calm never closes print postage
for any letters or any packages at your
convenience 24/7 print postage for any
class of mail right from your own
computer the exact amount of postage
every time never under pay or over pay
again stamps calm saves you time and
money which you can use to grow your
business stamps comb brings all the
amazing services of the US Postal
Service right to your fingertips tips
buy and print official US postage for
any letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer
printer stamps uh comes calm makes it
easy they'll send you a digital scale
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps comm will even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
needs no need to lease an expensive
postage meter and there are no long term
commitment so right now you too can
enjoy the stamps.com service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital sale
scale sorry go-to stamp song click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Burpee URR that
stamps comm enter bur alright let's get
into some of the questions here for the
week oh here's some upcoming dates
Baltimore Maryland October 18th
this Thursday I'll be at the the modal
model lyric early show is sold out late
show tick tickets still available
Atlantic City New Jersey Borgata resort
October 19th two shows Phoenix Arizona
October 26 Comerica theater evening show
says sold out standup live mm oh I'm
doing a WoW I'm doing a live podcast
once again the only time I've ever done
it before was the same place stand-up
live Monday morning podcast taping
there's still a few tickets still
available New York City Madison Square
Garden I'll be there November 7th and
Chicago November 8th through 10th I'll
be tickets still available for the Late
Show on the 8th oh my god the Late Show
set means I'm doing two shows Jesus
Christ Chicago oh you guys always
supported me man I really appreciate
that
alright let's get into some of the
questions here for the week alright
sociopath island you'll Billy one punch
check out Psychopaths it's an anime show
about the same idea you had last week
throwing all the psychos on an island
hey you know what man I got a fight I
actually just watched the I watched the
clip of that I think I'm gonna get into
that show as far as I can tell because
there's no talking or anything there's
no dialogue and it looks like there's a
group of people who aren't sociopaths
and for some reason they have to go to
so psycho island and [ __ ] maybe
rescue somebody
I don't know but it's definitely
interesting and as always i came up with
a great idea that not only did somebody
else already have they've already
developed it that happens to me all the
time in the worst case of it was the
time when I wanted to do a parody of a
drum instructional video and someone's
like somebody already did that I was
like you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
Fran Armisen all right dude you called
it DNA yo bill listening to the
throwback last week and you mentioned
how even if you don't bank online your
[ __ ] is online anyways that was 2010 now
you're coming down on ancestry DNA test
and I think history is going to repeat
itself this article basically says that
even if you don't send your DNA into the
internet they will be able to deduce all
of your DNA info anyways yeah they need
like six million people they're halfway
there
all felons you know have to give up
their [ __ ] DNA and then all these
[ __ ] mouth-breathing [ __ ] morons
who just trust people are sending in
their [ __ ] saliva to the [ __ ]
Internet it's so stupid the article says
once the register reached 3 million oh
ok I was wrong they'll be able to
identify the people who haven't sent in
their DNA currently they're into 1
million mark dude you called it yeah and
it's like what are they gonna do with it
like the fact that you're gonna sit
there and you're gonna depend on all of
these [ __ ] people to do the right
thing I mean look look what's going like
everybody knows what the [ __ ] is going
on in the world right now but you can't
really talk about it because they got
the game so sewed up that you're viewed
is like a sociopath or [ __ ]
unamerican if you even remotely
criticize what the [ __ ] people who
are making tons of money off of other
people's misery are and they're just
gonna have you it's gonna be game set
[ __ ] match and I'm not even read that
article because it's gonna be so [ __ ]
depressing because people are just
they're just going to keep doing it
[Music]
yeah it's just gonna be like I think it
all ties into how people that are in
control if they're doing wrong things it
makes you paranoid and you cannot have
enough information on people and then
also there's no [ __ ] way that these
people when they go to those Bilderberg
[ __ ] meetings there is no [ __ ] way
that they are not having hard core you
know I need to go to the hotel bar after
this and [ __ ] drink this meeting up
talks about the population problem and
climate change there's no [ __ ] way
that that they're not talking about that
[ __ ] and how the [ __ ] they're going to
handle it and how they're going to
survive and who else they're going to
determine it's going to survive and that
God has put us in power we have to make
these tough decisions which I mean I'd
learn like I have a solution on how to
you could [ __ ] solve those problems
but you know I don't know so I think
they're trying to get as much
information so they know you know I
think once they get everybody
microchipped then that's when they're
gonna start [ __ ] thin in the herd and
they need to do it quick and this right
here this train of thought is why I
don't watch the [ __ ] news because
that's everything that's going on and
everything that they're showing that's
what I can't even watch The Weather
Channel anymore I'm just like dude this
is like this is this is a [ __ ] done
deal here this is over
anyways buying a car hey let's get back
to some [ __ ] bread and circus here
buying a car dear Billy ball boy hey
Bill
first I just first just wanted to say
thank you for your show you put on in
Springfield it was fantastic and
definitely would love to see you come
back sometime I had a great time too
thank you I always listen to the
podcasts on my bus ride to school
anyways I am a sophomore in high school
and I just received my permit
ah good for you man that's a big day I
have a job and I'm saving up for a car I
was wondering what your first car ever
was and what kind of car would be good
for a first-timer like me and what
should I look forward
buying a car that would be beneficial
thanks - go [ __ ] yourself I had a 1983
Ford Ranger 4 cylinder 5 speed overdrive
black vinyl seats fire engine red the
long bed there was enough 2 wheel drive
nothing cool about it but I only had
19,000 miles on when I bought it so it
was definitely reliable I paid 5 grand
for it I went out got a loan and with
the job so you know I got a loan I
established credit and that type of [ __ ]
still remember my it was Danvers Savings
Bank 1 Conant Street Danvers Mass
something something something and my
payment was 138 dollars and 63 cents I
still [ __ ] remember that so if I was
you you're obviously gonna buy a used
car I mean I always loved the Honda's
and the Toyotas back in the day because
those engines would just last forever I
don't know what they're doing now but I
remember I I got some acting work and I
made some money but I've always been a
frugal son of a [ __ ] so rather than
buying a new car in like the late 90s I
bought a 1988 Honda Accord LX 5 speed
for to a 5-speed and I [ __ ] love that
car it had a hundred thousand miles on
it when I drove it and that [ __ ]
thing could cruise at a hundred miles an
hour still no [ __ ] problem it was
such a well-built car so if I was gonna
go used you know you got to be you got
to be careful with whatever the flashy
cars are like when I was a kid everybody
would try to go out buy the Burt
Reynolds [ __ ] Trans Am with the
screaming chicken of the flaming Eagle
whatever the [ __ ] they called it on the
hood and you just had to know that those
cars were they were driven like a sports
car [ __ ] burnouts and neutral drops
and all the [ __ ] that people used to do
trying to do the Jim Rockford backing it
up and whippin the [ __ ] front end
around so I don't know and I also liked
having a Ford or a car because I used to
like heading out with my friends
everybody could pile in
you know all depends on what you're
looking for but I would definitely I
would get something that is is that has
the reputation of lasting rather than I
don't know I mean you do want something
kind of cool it's right if you can blend
both those worlds something kind of cool
looking but also it's going to last I
would get something like that and you
know if you have to take out a little
bit of a loan you know you already got a
job that's [ __ ] cool you established
credit
you pay the [ __ ] off and then you know
then you're into that world right learn
about money and all in that [ __ ] all
right
Halloween costumes I got to wrap this up
quick here cuz I gotta get running here
dear Billy dear Billy's dear dr. Billy
Stein I have a two-year-old daughter
congratulations as well and I'm starting
to remember all this fun stuff we do
this autumn season jump and piles of
leave watch Halloween movies and try to
scare the [ __ ] out of ourselves by
running through the woods at night I
don't think I've ever heard you recall
any favorite Halloween costumes on
Halloween memories do you and Nia have
any place plans to dress up your
daughter also if you had a professional
costume and makeup team what would you
go for is Halloween at this point in
your life PS nothing goes better with a
cigar than apple cider nothing really
really well it just so happens I know
somebody who makes apple cider who also
happens to be one of my favorite
drummers of all time Tim Alexander from
Primus he has his own site or what the
[ __ ] is it called again
he just [ __ ] asked me if I wanted
some too and I told him I can't I'm
[ __ ] in sober October which I was and
now I'm not let's see Tim Alexander
cider the [ __ ] is if you're and if
you're into [ __ ] cider man okay herb
cider calm
what do we got here here we go yeah it's
called herb cider it's hard
herb cider is a craft site are produced
by world-renowned drummer Tim herb
Alexander and his wife Shama created
their first batch of cider in their
garage in the fall of 2016
yeah dude he gave us some of that stuff
it's [ __ ] delicious and then I
brought me gave me a whole case of it so
I brought it down to the comedy store
and I gave it out just a bunch of comics
never he was just like kind of [ __ ]
went nuts for it so anyways um let's get
back to the Halloween stuff um okay what
are you asking me do I have any plans to
dress up yeah I mean I usually dress up
like John Bonham or a [ __ ] you know
maybe I was gonna go as Vinnie Paul this
year you know just as he passed away
this year or something like that and as
far as our daughter my wife was talking
she was gonna dress dress her up like
Bruno Mars because our daughter has like
curly hair she's so [ __ ] cute it's
ridiculous but at the last second she
went to the costume place and she got us
all like matching like skeleton costumes
which I thought was a little hacky going
I was just when she told me the idea but
then I saw them they're really [ __ ]
cool and it's gonna look cute you know
we're having a Nia does the kid
Halloween party every year so we have a
bunch of kids come over so I guess I
couldn't dress up like something too
scary and I guess if I dressed up like
John Bonham or Vinnie Paul they wouldn't
know who it was and they'd probably just
look like a scary [ __ ] guy
[Music]
so anyways gotta answer your question I
don't even [ __ ] know I'm just
thinking about smoking a cigar drinking
some [ __ ] out the sight of them are
underrated going to things by yourself
no girls no friends no family no problem
hey there Billy freckle glutes my whole
life I had this dilemma regarding going
to events or social gatherings alone
I've even had friends say that I
if you eat alone at a restaurant or
McDonald's or something that's social
suicide well no one ever told me
I love going to ship on myself now this
can be really debilitating especially if
your work schedule sucks you live in a
town or a million other reasons but I
figured a big figure but I finally
figured it out who cares
half the time that you that you do have
a group to go to something with people
Plake want to change plans times etc if
there's an event you really want to go
to you have to think about yourself and
just go even if you are by yourself and
I write this as I'm a little nervous
wanting to go to see a comedy show
tonight that I have to drive a bit too
that's out of the way and go there alone
well I'll be honest with you I just
don't sit up front if you go to a comedy
show alone but other than that there's
no problem with it and then you know
usually meet people you know I just go
to ship on myself all the time baseball
games football games all that [ __ ]
except I wouldn't talk to anybody
because I was a [ __ ] lunatic anyways
I say this constant I say there's
constantly having to deal with the issue
including your tours some very good
friends dropped out of going to your
show show well I don't blame them I just
feel like for me it puts you in this
spot of oh now I just can't go and your
instinct is that you getting that
experience is impossible what and your
experience is impossible well [ __ ] that
you might as well go because if you
think of it that way you will miss out
on a thousand bill bird specials
sporting events holidays and before you
know it you're in you're at the end of
your road and have all these piled up
regrets forget about the stigma of solo
attending things live your life and have
fun did you guys get my stomach growling
there try not to eat like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] here and that's all you have to
say that's all I have to say about that
can't wait for you to see you at the
garden
you ranty bastard go [ __ ] yourself
thanks for the laughs inspiration and
one more time go [ __ ] yourself yeah I do
go if you want to go go just because
someone else can't go I mean what are
they what are they the the [ __ ]
dictator of what you go to absolutely go
to you by yourself and then chat up a
couple of ladies who are you here with
I came by myself it's actually like a
[ __ ] strong move all my friends
flaked and I was like [ __ ] I'm gonna
go I'm sure I'll meet somebody nice to
look at I ran into you and then you're
in right gonna fire my baby gonna hold
her tight gonna have an afternoon
delight I came to the [ __ ] all by myself
and now I'm talking to you
would you like to see my dick Hey I was
just [ __ ] around please don't be to
me
ade sorry um anyways would you like to
see my dick
I asked [ __ ] permission why you
flipping out please don't put back on
Twitter sorry I'm losing my [ __ ] mind
you know what I realize - I'm in my
[ __ ] [ __ ] apartment here and and
and people gonna be hearing me down the
hall singing about me to stuff and I
don't want to trigger anybody alright -
[ __ ]
alright Go Red Sox go Patriots Patrick
mahomes is the real deal I miss defense
in the NFL that's all I have to say go
[ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in on you
on Thursday